google kubernetes engine or gke is
google's secured and fully managed
kubernetes service
that now includes a revolutionary
autopilot mode
it allows you to build deploy and run
fast reliable apps and services
but how do you ensure that the
infrastructure you provision to run
those services remains reliable
and available for developers today i'm
going to show you how to manage gke
infrastructure at scale with cloud
operations
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
imagine getting a ticket like this one
you know that a service is having an
issue
and the service owners are asking you to
help them determine whether it's being
caused by the gke infrastructure they're
running on
the problem is that there's a default
namespace and every cluster in your org
how can you possibly find the one you're
after let's see how cloud operations
can help from the monitoring overview
screen let's click on the gke dashboard
by looking at the last 6 hours of data
and expanding the alert timeline
we can in fact confirm that there are no
alerts in the default namespace
we can also confirm that there aren't
any issues with our nodes
let's have a look at the workloads in
that namespace to see if there are any
issues there
we can find the workload by clicking on
view all
and then searching for the namespace
where we know it's running
it looks like there is a memory
utilization alert for this workload
let's check to see if there are any
infrastructure issues that may be
causing this
let's click on metrics and select memory
under node metrics
here we can see that the nodes aren't
having any memory alerts or issues
so we can rule out infrastructure as a
probable cause for this particular
incident
and we can reply to the original message
letting them know that memory issues are
constrained to their specific service
being able to take a very limited amount
of information about a problem and
quickly determine whether an
infrastructure of issues at fault is
fantastic
as an operator your time is incredibly
valuable and being able to quickly
eliminate your infrastructure as a
culprit is
great but what about the service owner
let's have a look at another example
does your inbox look like this when
there's a problem of any kind
this might happen if there's an alert
flood caused by a widespread issue
or it might happen just because there
are a lot of alerts that might be
triggered for
any number of reasons how can you
quickly dig through this mess and figure
out what's actually important and
whether your service is impacted
let's see how cloud operations can help
let's see if we can figure out whether
our service was impacted by an
infrastructure issue
from the monitoring overview screen
let's go to the gke dashboard and have a
look at the behavior of our system over
the last day
when we expand the alerts timeline we
can see that there are two node alerts
let's have a look at the resource
associated with the alert
we can see that we are getting high cpu
alerts in the metrics tab we can confirm
elevated cpu utilization of the node
when we look at container metrics we can
see that there are a number of services
that
are running on this particular node some
of them did not see increased
utilization during interval
however at least two services did see
elevated cpus that corresponds to
elevated seputalization on the node
so we can confirm that not only was our
service impacted by increased resource
utilization of the node
but another service was as well
thanks for joining me today we saw how
cloud operations can help you quickly
isolate or eliminate infrastructure
issues from a
limited set of data we also saw how to
use the timeline to quickly filter
alerts
to determine whether your service is
having an issue or not
i hope this helps you to keep your gk
infrastructure reliable and available
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to like and subscribe to never miss out
on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon